BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
IKAI LAN: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to a very special
edition of
Google Developers Live.
My name is Ikai Lan from
the Apps Script team.
Joining us today is a
very special guest.
This is Michael Manoochehri from
the Google BigQuery team.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Hello, everybody.
How's it going?
How are you doing?
Good to see you, Ikai.
IKAI LAN: Good to
see you, too.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
It's been a while.
IKAI LAN: So we used to work
together in the San Francisco
office, and he's visiting
New York City.
And this is his first time in
the Google New York office.
So what do you think so far?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's
a big building.
It's a great place.
IKAI LAN: It's a very
big building.
There are a lot of people
that work here
in many, many stories.
You're here for the
Strata Conference.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
Strata New York Hadoop World
Conference.
So it's actually a
big conference.
It's about big data, a lot
of analytics, lot of new
technologies.
So I'm here to talk about
Google BigQuery at that
conference.
IKAI LAN: And speaking of Google
BigQuery, that's what
this special Google Developers
Live show is about.
So today, we're going to be
talking about how to use
Google BigQuery to do analysis
on large data sets and how to
pipe that into Apps Script
so you can quickly peel
dashboards or integrate with
Google Apps technology such as
Gmail, Calendar, or
Spreadsheets.
So before we start the demo, why
don't you tell us a little
bit about BigQuery for the
people that aren't familiar?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: BigQuery
is a service for running ad
hoc analysis on really
large data sets.
And you can get the results
back quickly.
You can use a SQL-style
language, which allows you to
write your queries
quickly as well.
And my favorite part about
it is it's an API.
It's a RESTful API, so
you interact with
it through the API.
That means it's easy to build
applications with it.
It's easy to integrate into
your own applications.
So it's a very cool
technology.
It's actually based on some
internal technology that we
have at Google.
So we use it internally as well,
at least the underlying
technology behind it.
And I really like using it with
Apps Script, actually.
IKAI LAN: I was waiting
for that one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yeah, exactly.
IKAI LAN: So tell us about who's
using BigQuery and what
other types of things they're
using it for.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah, so
a lot of cool applications.
We have some companies using it
for social game analytics.
So they're using BigQuery to
analyze massive amounts of
data from games, for example.
We have people using it for
transportation industry,
hospitality industry,
anything where
there's lots of big data.
So people love using it to
integrate with their own
applications, like I said.
So people are building
visualizations around it.
We have a lot of visualization
partners using it as well.
So it's very cool.
Internally at Google, we use
it for different projects,
actually with Apps Script.
Because Apps Script is a great
way to build work flows and
prototype UIs around it.
So we actually have been using
it with some ads data.
We have some people looking at
just a general server log
data, things like that.
So it's really easy
to get started.
They're very complementary
technologies.
Because BigQuery's great for
asking questions about large
data sets and getting
a response back.
But once you get that response
back, you need to do
something with it.
You need to visualize
that data.
You need to automate
There's lots of things
you can do.
And that's where Apps
Script comes in.
It's very cool.
So I like to say, use BigQuery
for that large data, analyzing
this massive data that it's hard
to wrap your head around.
And then bring it into Apps
Script and actually do
something with it, like
visualize it, analyze it.
IKAI LAN: So when
you're talking
about large data, what's--
I mean, I know you're going to
show us a demo fairly soon,
very quickly.
So why don't we jump
into that?
I mean, when you say large data,
are you talking like
kilobytes or megabytes?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: BigQuery
scales very well, so we're
talking terabytes.
IKAI LAN: Terabytes!
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
waiting for someone to bring
us some petabytes.
I'd like to try it on that.
But when I say big data, I mean
literally a lot of data,
billions of records.
I'm going to show you a
data set that I think
of as pretty small.
It's about 100 million records,
Wikipedia revision data.
But we can scale very well.
So terabytes, I'd like
to see if you
have multiple terabytes.
Bring it to us and we'll
talk about it.
IKAI LAN: So much for the days
when 640 kilobytes were all
you needed.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
I remember that.
IKAI LAN: Imagine that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Those
40-meg hard drives.
Oh, my god, 40-meg hard drive!
IKAI LAN: You know, I even
remember when I had my 386.
I had a 50-megabyte
hard drive.
And it was like huge.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: How will
I ever fill this up?
IKAI LAN: Boom!
Head explode.
So why don't you go and show
us a little bit of BigQuery
before we dive into the
Apps Script portion?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Let's
start with the classic
BigQuery kind of demo.
So this is the BigQuery
web UI.
I mentioned that BigQuery
uses an API.
But when you sign up for
BigQuery, you actually have
access to this web UI.
And this lets you run
some sample queries
on some of the data.
We provide some public data
sets for you to test on.
And we're going to do the
demo with the data sets.
This is sort of the classic
of BigQuery demo query.
This is going to query over
some Wikipedia revision
history that we have.
So we have the entire Wikipedia
revision history up
until about 2010.
IKAI LAN: So what is
a revision history?
What does that mean?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So every
time anybody change a
Wikipedia page, this is a
recording of that change.
IKAI LAN: Wow.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
it may be a username.
It might include an IP address
plus some information like a
message about it.
But what's cool about
this data--
and we show this demo a lot.
What's cool about this data is
you can see what the most
revised articles were.
So before we get into that, I'm
actually going to show you
how to do that through Apps
Script, but let me just show
you a quick count.
IKAI LAN: So I'm looking at this
right now and this looks
a lot like SQL to me.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yes, that's right.
As I mentioned before, it's
a SQL-like language.
It's not standard SQL,
but it's very close.
So the idea is to get you
up to speed quickly.
And a lot of people have used
SQL with relational databases.
So this is a way to just kind
of get you started.
Also, if you've ever used like
Mongo or some of those
document stores, oftentimes
when you need to aggregate
queries, you're writing
a MapReduce function.
You're literally writing
a mapper and a reducer.
And this gives you the same kind
of aggregate query power
but expressed in SQL,
which is very cool.
So anyway, I just ran this.
And it took just a few
seconds, actually.
I processed it, and this
number is quite large.
But you can see it's something
like we're going to look at
223 million records.
So that's a pretty
big data set.
If you were using a relational
database on a single-node
server, this would pretty much
take forever to kind of run.
IKAI LAN: Well, not a
server that I build.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
not an Ikai Lan server.
IKAI LAN: But OK.
A normal person server.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And
to be fair, this is
just a count query.
So actually, that's
pretty fast with
a relational database.
But if you want to do some kind
of aggregate queries,
like what are the sums of the
amount of characters changed,
these kind of queries
are very difficult
for relational databases.
IKAI LAN: Because what would
these look like when you're
doing the query?
You'd actually have to go in
and you would have to check
every single row.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's
a table scan, basically.
And what's interesting about the
design of BigQuery is that
we embrace the table scan.
We actually can run a table scan
for every query that's
designed to do that unlike a
relational database, where
that's a scary thought.
So anyway, so this gives you a
sense of the data set we're
going to play with.
So we're going to just
start from scratch.
I've created a new spreadsheet
in Google Drive.
And we're going to actually
run through the process of
integrating with BigQuery.
IKAI LAN: So what we're doing
now is Google BigQuery is
very, very good with
data analysis.
And they made some very good
decisions on the team, which
was, let's build a robust,
powerful API so that people
could build their own
visualizations.
Because if they were to take
time away from doing
BigQuery-related things and
making table scans awesome--
which again, very,
very scary--
that's less time to really
improve the service.
Now, Apps Script is very good
for building UIs quickly, as
many of you may know.
Hopefully, you're joining
us as Apps Script users.
But some of you guys will
be BigQuery users.
And when you see how quickly
we're able to build UIs, what
Michael is going to show us is
how he uses the built-in
spreadsheet UI to work
with BigQuery.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
So let's get started.
The first thing you need to know
is BigQuery needs to be
activated through the Google
Developers console.
So what I've done here is I've
actually just created my own
test demo, BigQuery
demo project.
And the important thing to
note for building an
application is the
project number.
So everything with BigQuery is
actually attached to a Google
Developers project.
And so here I've gone to
developers.google.com/console.
IKAI LAN: I notice that you've
got upstartstartup.biz.
What's going on?
Is this like your side thing?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That's my
little-- yeah, well, that's my
test account.
IKAI LAN: Superstealth?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's
my non-stealth startup.
I'm sorry for anyone who
wanted that domain
name, by the way.
I don't actually use
it for startups.
So I'm going to note the
project number here.
And so here under Apps Script,
I've opened up the Apps Script
script editor.
IKAI LAN: And you do
this via Tools.
And just to show people,
we do this via
Tools and Script Editor.
So for those of you that are a
BigQuery user and new to Apps
Script, this is how you get to
Script Editor from Google
Spreadsheets.
This is where you would create
your custom functions and the
things that you want the
spreadsheet to do, things you
wanted to automate.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Definitely.
And to save time, I've
actually pasted
some code in here.
But once we've created our API
console project, I'm also
going to activate
the Google API.
So that's under the Script
Editor for Apps Script and
under Use Google APIs.
So I'm going to click on that.
And it's going to open up a
window that'll give me a
collection of APIs that
I'll have access to.
I'm going to toggle on
the BigQuery API.
It says version 2 here
because we're
currently on that version.
But that's the only one.
You don't need an API key.
This is a common question
I have.
Do we need an API key?
No, just toggle on
the BigQuery API.
So that's it.
Now, the libraries for our
project are updated.
That's great.
And in my code, the first
thing I'm going to do is
create a variable that holds
my project number.
Because we're going to refer
to that in the code later.
So I'm going to paste in the
project number that comes from
my API console.
And that's it.
I should be ready to go, to
start actually using this.
IKAI LAN: And for the BigQuery
users, this is our cloud-based
editor for Apps Script.
So it'll do things like auto
completion and just basic
editor functions.
I don't want to call it an
IDE, but you can run and
deploy applications all
from the web, all
straight from the cloud.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So I'm
actually going to move the
Script Editor over so
people can see the
spreadsheet behind it.
I think that'll actually help
see what's going on.
So I'm going to run some
of these functions
in the Script Editor.
And it's going to update
this live.
So let me find that.
IKAI LAN: Now what you're
seeing here is that this
spreadsheet is the parent
container of this script.
So when you run this code and
it refers to a parent
spreadsheet, well, you'll
see this code.
For instance, varssspreadsheet
app.getactivespreadsheet And
Michael's doing this globally.
You don't have to do that.
Usually, it's better not to.
This is referring to the parent
spreadsheet, so it very
easily talks to a UI that
you can work with.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Definitely.
Yeah, this is sort of a
stripped-down example, just in
practice to kind of show you
some of the querying features.
But yeah, there's much more
complicated scripts that
actually have sort of a
better design there.
So here, I've actually
hard-coded in a SQL statement.
So you saw me in that web UI run
basically a SQL statement.
Here's one that's going to
find the top most revised
articles from Wikipedia.
And before I do anything else,
I'm actually going to use the
Browser.msgBox function to
just pop up the result.
And you'll see what a
raw query result is.
Now, don't be scared.
It's not going to look
like what we're
going to do later on.
So I'm going to try
to run this.
And the first thing you'll see
is it's going to ask me for
authorization.
Because BigQuery requires
authorization
from the user to use.
And so I'm going to say, yes.
I would like this application
to be able to read my data
from BigQuery.
I'm going to grant access.
And now I can run the script.
So once that authorization
step is done,
you can run the script.
I'm going to run it right now.
And you should see--
it's going to take a
few seconds to run.
IKAI LAN: What you're going to
see is that you're running the
OnOpen method.
So the OnOpen is a hook.
And if you look at the code in
the OnOpen method-- let's
scroll up a little bit.
What you're doing is you're
adding a menu item.
So now instead of--
you didn't run any functions.
You added additional menus
to your spreadsheet.
That's a very, very cool
feature of Apps Script.
I'm pretty sure that
you wanted to show
us something else.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yes, that's right.
Oh, that's right.
I'm sorry about that.
I looked at the wrong
function.
That's right.
So we'll be referring
to that later.
So actually, let's
run the query.
Thank you, Ikai.
We're going to run
the actual query.
So this is going to do what the
web UI for BigQuery was
doing before, and it's going
to return a raw response.
And you can see it here,
behind here.
This is the raw JSON response,
so BigQuery returns results as
a JSON object.
So what we're going to do now
is we're going to take this
result set.
I just wanted to show you this
to just sort of give you an
idea of what the raw
API looks like.
We're going to take this
response, and we're actually
going to put it into the Apps
Script in a tabular form in
the spreadsheet.
So I'm going to comment out
the method that does that.
And we're going to uncomment
this code.
Now, this code is actually going
to take that response.
And it's going to format it in
a way that will actually put
it into the spreadsheet.
So basically, just to show you
what I'm doing here, I'm just
going through the results set,
the table rows that have been
brought back from BigQuery.
And I'm actually going to say,
for each of the results, put
them into a two-dimensional
array, and we're going to pop
that array into the spreadsheet
using Apps Script.
IKAI LAN: So what's really cool
here is that I'm looking
at this code, and I'm
seeing that you're
saying query the data.
Now, because this is Apps
Script, you'll be able to do
things like this.
You'll be able to type
BigQuery.jobs.
And you'll see that the code
editor auto-completes the code
that you want to use.
And that's why when he gets
back the query results, if
sometimes you don't remember
what the function is called,
Michael will type
query results.
And you'll hit a dot.
And you'll see, oh, I have get
total rows or get schema.
And this is all comes for free
when you use Google Apps.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I love this editor.
This is one of the best
things about Apps
Script is the cool editor.
It just makes it so easy
to build these things.
OK, so I just updated, or
uncommented that code.
And we're going to run this
function again, and we're not
going to see that JSON object
pop up in the box.
What we're actually going to
see is the spreadsheet
populated with the values
from that code.
So remember, these
are the top 10--
magic!
These are the top 10--
I promised I would never run
this again because I'm always
running this query, but these
are the top 10 most revised
Wikipedia articles.
This is the last time.
But it's funny because the
results are really funny.
You've got George W Bush
followed by the list of
wrestling employees.
IKAI LAN: It is-- wow.
I mean, those are things that
are constantly in flux, right?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yes, exactly.
Although, yes.
So you can see you can actually
drill down and run
other queries to see why these
are the most revised.
Sometimes they're
controversial.
Sometimes they're just a big
names, et cetera, et cetera.
IKAI LAN: I can't believe
the Wii has been
edited that many times.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I know.
That's kind of hard
to believe.
Is it really that
controversial?
And the controversial Britney
Spears as well.
IKAI LAN: Very controversial.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, so
let's add something else.
Now what we want to
do is we want to
visualize these results.
So I have a function down here
which builds a chart.
And it takes the data from the
spreadsheet and actually makes
a bar chart out of it.
The visualization functions--
you know much more
about this than I do.
But I find them to be really
awesome, like to take this
data and be able to build the
chart automatically in the
spreadsheet, it's just great.
IKAI LAN: And we've got some
great tutorials online when
you search.
When you search on Google for
Google Apps Script charts
tutorial, they'll teach you
the process of building a
charts dashboard.
But for now, we're doing
a very basic one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this
one, this is one thing I
wanted to highlight.
BigQuery currently supports
four data types--
integer, floating point,
Boolean, and string.
And this particular chart would
like to have either a
number or a string
as the values.
So what I'm doing here in this
code-- and this is all on the
BigQuery Apps Script
tutorial that's on
the Apps Script site.
What I'm doing here is I'm just
finding anything that is
a Boolean or a string, I'm
saying, make that a
column-type string.
Anything that's an integer or
floating point, make that a
column-type number.
It's pretty easy to use.
It's just a way to take the
data values coming from
BigQuery and turning them into
something that the charts
method really likes.
So I have this ready to go.
I'm going to uncomment this part
of my RunQuery function
that will actually pass the
information that you see here
in the spreadsheet to
that chart function.
And this just has dimensions,
like the color of the chart,
how big the chart
is going to be.
IKAI LAN: So this is one way of
building UIs in Apps Script.
It's called UI service, where
you programmatically construct
the UIs from various components,
and you used
composite patterns to build
up these complex UIs.
And so now, it looks like you're
just building a chart,
and you're setting certain
variables, and you're setting
the data sources.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly.
So let's save that.
I'm going to run this function
one more time.
And if you go back to the parent
chart when this is
done, we should see a chart.
IKAI LAN: It's actually running
the query again.
So it's not just taking this
and generating the chart.
It's running the query
again in case
the data set is updated.
Which it actually hasn't, but
in many cases, it might.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And you
see, I actually have a title
here about Shakespeare.
That's because I have another
query in there that's a
Shakespeare one.
But we can change that in
the code right here.
That's just a label,
basically.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Follow the bug.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's right.
And actually, we can change
that right now.
We can say Wikipedia revision.
IKAI LAN: Wikipedia revisions.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Most revised.
And that's it.
IKAI LAN: Let's go ahead, save
it, and run the function.
And let's go back
to the screen.
You'll notice that-- oop!
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That's
because I went over the free
query limit for BigQuery.
IKAI LAN: You've been running
this query all day long.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I know.
It's true.
I have been.
IKAI LAN: Well, that kind
of took the steam
out of our demo there.
But you guys all saw,
it was a chart.
It was a bar chart.
And you can build all kinds
of charts in App Script.
You can use a pie chart.
That's also a very good one.
Line chart, they have
scatter charts.
There are all kinds of charts
that are exposed via the App
Script charts API.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And what a
lot of people do is actually
do time series.
So they will group
by a time bucket.
And that's a great thing for
charts that go over line
charts and these
kind of things.
IKAI LAN: Do you have an example
of something that
people like to graph
in a time series?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Oh,
Yeah, definitely.
I was talking about
social games.
Think about daily use of
something over the life of the
game, like how many people are
playing over the life of the
game, things like that.
IKAI LAN: And you would
generate this from,
say, raw logs data.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Oh, yeah.
This is a common use
case for BigQuery.
IKAI LAN: So what do people
commonly do when they have
lots of raw logs that they want
to get into BigQuery?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Do you mean
how do you actually load
that data in?
IKAI LAN: I mean, this
is really cool.
But I can't imagine that many
people are building dashboards
based on Wikipedia hits.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: These are
just public data sets for
testing, but you're right.
To get your data in, first you
stage, either CSV, and we
recently started supporting JSON
objects for nested and
repeated values.
So in your raw source file,
stage that data in Google
Cloud Storage.
And we didn't have much
time to talk about
Google Cloud Storage.
But basically, it's binary
storage in the cloud.
Stage your files there, and then
you tell the BigQuery API
where those files are.
And it will load that data into
BigQuery for you to analyze.
BigQuery is append only.
You don't have CRUD operations
like a standard database.
But it's really a tool
for analysis.
So once you get that data in, no
indexing required once the
ingestion job is done.
You can start running queries.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
You would not be using BigQuery,
for instance, the
way you'd be using be
an SQL database.
Because logs are very good
because unless we've got some
Arnold Schwarzenegger
"Terminator" thing going back
on, you're not going to go back
in time and delete logs.
You're not going to be
wanting to do that.
So you mentioned Google
Cloud Storage.
Now, Google Cloud Storage
also has an API.
There are two ways
to upload files.
There's a web UI.
Actually, there are
multiple ways.
There's a command-line tool.
And there's also an API.
So what people frequently
do is--
do people use the API and
frequently just push?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
people do all kinds of stuff.
So they'll use the API.
They'll use the command-line
client and actually build the
server-side scripting stuff that
pushes it up to Google
Cloud Storage and then kicks off
a BigQuery ingestion job.
BigQuery itself also has
a command-line client.
So a lot of people
use that as well.
We also have a lot of
partners who do
things like data ingestion.
So if you go to the BigQuery
website at
developers.google.com/bigquery,
there's links to all of our
partners that do some of these
transformation and ETL jobs.
So there's a lot of
ways to do it.
IKAI LAN: And ETL means?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Extract,
Transform, and Load.
IKAI LAN: I always have to ask
him because I never forget.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I
always get it confused--
IKAI LAN: I never remember.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
--with GTL.
IKAI LAN: What's GTL?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It means
Gym, Tanning, and Laundry.
IKAI LAN: Oh, right,
right, GTLs.
And that's--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That show.
IKAI LAN: --weekend plan?
Oh, it's a show.
I didn't realize.
See, I'm so out of touch
with the cool people.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: You're
just so deep in the Apps
Script world.
IKAI LAN: Look at
how cool he is.
He's a hipster.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
He's an HTTPster.
So that's all really
cool stuff.
And I think that when you're
developing, especially in Apps
Script, one thing that's really
good to do is first
off, get your data.
Get a small data set
into BigQuery.
Use the command line or web
tools to figure out which
queries you want to run
and what variables
you want to be dynamic.
And once you're doing that, when
you want to develop a UI,
instead of constantly making
calls to BigQuery, a very good
way of building a UI is to stub
out the data first in a
spreadsheet.
And because this is a
spreadsheet, you have a
built-in UI for editing data.
So you can quickly create a
sample data set, figure out
the UI that you want to build.
And once you've got those two
pieces working together-- they
don't even have to be built
by the same person--
you can quickly wire
them together
using the script editor.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Definitely.
I actually do that
all the time.
That's the way I use Apps
Script as well.
IKAI LAN: I mean, you could
work with live data.
But there's always going
to be a delay.
Now, this is a relatively
fast query.
But there are some queries
that will take longer.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: BigQuery
generally returns results on
the order of seconds.
But if you have a lot of data
and you're running a very
complex query, it's not going
to take 2 seconds.
It might take 10 or 20,
something like that.
IKAI LAN: And you don't want
to have to wait that every
time you just want to make a
change to how the chart looks
or which chart you
want to use.
You want to be able to very
quickly get very fast
turnaround.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So the
other thing I wanted to
mention is, like I said earlier,
BigQuery is a premium
product, but you get
a free quota.
If you want to put your
own data in, you
have to flip on billing.
But we do have these public data
sets that you can test
with and kind of get a
handle of what the
data will look like.
And the data sets kind of look
like some of the log data sets
you mentioned that you
use on your own.
But to get started, it's really
just a matter of going
to the BigQuery website, signing
up, and then you're
ready to go.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And once you get that going and
you have connected to Apps
Script, you get all the
power of App Script.
You get to use things like
Google Calendar.
You could publish the results
to Google Doc.
You can email the results out
every day as a nightly report.
There's just a lot of things
that you could do.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
actually, the Cron
functionality with Apps Script
is really useful.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
And Cron is--
for those people not that used
to Unix, it's to schedule
tasks and clock triggers.
To use a clock trigger, you
would say something like,
every night at 4:00
AM, do this.
Do this BigQuery thing, generate
this chart, and email
it out to people.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's true.
A lot of people that are using
a spreadsheet functionality,
they might be analysts.
They might be making reports.
But they're not people that
would write SQL or be able to
kind of develop these kind
of applications.
So using the scheduler task,
you can actually
say, run this overnight.
Get the results back, and their
report is ready to go.
They can actually use it.
They can paste it into
something else.
They can, like you said,
email it to somebody,
email it to the CEO.
There's lots of cool stuff you
can do with very little code
just by toggling this or that.
IKAI LAN: I'm always
emailing the CEO.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's right.
IKAI LAN: I'm like,
dear Larry.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Dear Larry.
IKAI LAN: Dear Larry.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I've got an idea.
IKAI LAN: I have an idea.
So we're just about running
out of time.
And before we finish this show,
I'd like to plug couple
of things that you're doing.
So why don't you tell us what
you and the team are up to?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
tomorrow, I'm going to give a
talk about BigQuery, along with
Jim Caputo, who's the
engineering lead for BigQuery.
We're going to be at the Strata
Conference in the morning.
We're going to give
a talk there.
So generally check us
out if you're there.
Also, our buddy Ilya Grigorik,
who's on the Chrome team, and
another buddy of ours, Brian
from GitHub, are going to talk
about how they use BigQuery
to analyze GitHub data,
which is very cool.
It's going to be very funny.
So if you're at Strata, you
should check those out.
My partner in crime, Ryan Boyd,
is going to be at New
York GDG tonight.
And we're going to go to Boston
on Thursday and hang
out with the Boston GDG at
the upcoming hack/reduce
Hackerspace.
So that's going to be great.
IKAI LAN: And I'm also going
to be at the GDG.
But I don't have--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's right.
IKAI LAN: I'm not adding
any value to that.
I'm just in a completely
supporting role.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Ikai,
you're always adding value.
IKAI LAN: No, that's not true.
But if you're coming to GDG,
that's what you're going to
hear about.
You're going to hear some
more about BigQuery.
And if you're in Boston,
definitely stop by-- what did
you call it?
Hack--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah, it's
an upcoming Hackerspace.
But they're actually hosting
the Boston GDG this week.
IKAI LAN: Right.
OK, so they're hosting
the Boston GDG.
And Strata, I think that you
already have to have tickets
to be able to attend that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's right.
If you're there, check it out.
And otherwise, you'll catch us
at a GDG or catch us on GDL in
the future.
IKAI LAN: And of course, if
you've been watching this live
show, we will be posting a
recording of this show online.
So you'll be able to watch it
as many times you want.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Definitely.
I'm sure you're going
to want to.
IKAI LAN: People will.
People will.
So thank you guys
very much again.
I want to thank Michael
Manoochehri for coming out and
joining us today.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Thanks
for having me, Ikai.
IKAI LAN: No problem.
Thank you for coming out.
Come and join us any time.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Cool.
Sounds great.
IKAI LAN: Any time.
Any time you're in New York,
we'll have a desk for you.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Awesome.
Thank you.
IKAI LAN: Thank you
guys for watching.
And we'll see you guys
on Thursday.
[MUSIC PLAYING]